we're not actually afraid of making
mistakes we're afraid of making mistakes
and who's going to see us
we're afraid of making mistakes and
somebody's going to make a comment on
that video or somebody's going to laugh
at us right you'll sing in your shower
but you won't sing on the street corner
why because you're afraid of other
people's judgment and that's not a good
enough reason for you not to take action
and we'll hide under this label of
perfectionists and we see that as a
positive because you want to make
everything great but perfectionist
really is you being afraid of other
people's judgment of you of you being
seen as less than perfect and that's not
your message what's your message to the
world is your message never create
anything until it's perfect is the
message that you want to leave to your
kids or your grandkids is going to be
don't ever chase anything down unless
it's perfect that's not your message
but it's what you're living
that's what too many people are living
because you're afraid to just take the
action
and so you need to start living your
actual message